hello i'm darren jordan in doha with the
top stories here on al jazeera we start
with breaking news and we're getting
reports that
the ousted leader in myanmar has just
been sentenced to four years in jail on
a number of different charges well
florence louis joins us live now from
kuala lumpur florence so aung sangsuchi
had faced numerous charges in the
prospect of over 100 years in jail talk
us through those charges and what the
court's verdict was
that's right so these were the first
verdicts in the about a dozen charges
that she faces remember she was um
arrested she was detained on the first
of february which was the day of the
coup and then she's on several trials
there are some charges against her which
haven't even been brought to trial but
these are the very first verdicts and
these verdicts had been deferred from a
week ago now we're hearing that she in
fact we've confirmed with the source um
on the ground in myanmar that she's been
sentenced to two years on the charge of
incitement as well as two years for
breaking coronavirus rules now her other
defendants the deposed president win min
and also another high-ranking former
official of the nld government that's
national league for democracy aung san
tsuji's political party has also been
found guilty and sentenced to prison and
we don't have any other details beyond
that so we don't know if they are going
to be sent to prison immediately and
normally as well courts do
allow sentences to run consec um
concurrently instead of consecutively so
if she's been sentenced for two years
for one crime and two years for another
crime sometimes these sentences can run
concurrently which means she'll end up
spending two years in prison rather than
four we don't know if that's happening
in this case we have to remember also
though that these are not the only
verdicts and the only charges and the
only trials she's facing there are
several more the junta has charged us
her with corruption she's also been
charged with breaching the official
secrets act and the latest charges um
they piled on another corruption charge
as well as electoral fraud remember
electoral fraud is the justification
that the junta had used for seizing
power on the 1st of february this was a
day that the national league for
democracy the the representatives um
that the representatives um for
parliament were due to be sworn in and
that's when the junta stepped in and
seized power
now um
we're really not sure we're waiting for
more details about what's going to be
happening what's going to happen whether
she is going to be taken to prison now
aung san tsuji and her co-defendants
were kept in an undisclosed location
they had very limited access now this
verdict doesn't come as a surprise
political observers we've spoken to say
they wouldn't be surprised if she is
found guilty simply because the junta is
worried about her
popularity and they want to make sure
that she no longer has any um has any
say has any voice in the political arena
in myanmar
darren florence louis live for us there
in kuala lumpur florence thank you for
the update